joe biden
okay
a candidate
let's go to the phones at 617-830-4750
let's see let's first go to
uh oh you know who's on the phone donald
trump is holding on and last time
it was off the rails and that that
intrigues me i'm in an off the rails
sort of mood
what's going number one i'm in on
and you're in love we're all in love
together and when this happens
is this like parents is it siblings
cousins what like generation
relative to you is i've said that if
ivanka weren't my daughter perhaps i'd
be dating her
hold on let's slow down because there's
a lot there let's really think it
through
she's got the best body yeah she made a
lot of money as a model a tremendous
amount and then she went cold turkey and
gave it all up because she had to go to
college because i wanted
to go to college she goes to the best
college
the answer is really in you in the sense
of
what do you want your relationship to
look like
with these family members right because
i i could give you advice that would
smooth things over but to make you feel
like you're depressed
well hopefully yeah i mean just work on
being a normal person my friend i'm
gonna let you go
david you're born a certain way and
doesn't really change that much
okay i don't believe any of it that's
all the time i have for calls today
sorry i wasn't able to get to everybody
but we will take calls again
nobody that's a leader would not do what
i did
and i know there's a risk there's a
danger but that's okay
i just left walter reed medical center
and i learned so much in coronavirus
don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
we have the best
medical equipment don't be afraid of it
feel great like
better than i have in a long time be
afraid of it
i didn't feel so good don't
be afraid of it you're going to beat it
we have to put on a virus
don't be afraid of it and now i'm better
maybe i'm immune i don't be afraid of it
don't let it dominate don't let it take
over your life be
afraid of it don't let that happen
you're the greatest country in the world
you're afraid of it
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger do it but i had to do it
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
and it all happened very shortly and
they're all getting approved
and the vaccines are coming momentary
virus
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
battling a current infection
convalescence
of operation
today i'm pleased to make a truly
historic announcement in our battle
against the
china virus that will save countless
lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of
the
convalescent
convalescence
there it is the song of the summer
plasma
by joe woodward um a very very exciting
day
we have um an incredible
incredible what am i even what do we
even have on screen here are super chats
i don't know what that was on screen
some kind some kind of
analytical element was on screen briefly
there how embarrassing
we are standing by for all sorts of
different people some
orange some not for different rallies in
different parts of the country
it's the last day of campaigning it is
the election um
mike pence warming up the crowd if you
can imagine him doing such a thing
in traverse city michigan at amarga
rally
we are standing by with pbs always want
to make sure that we are both live
and in hd only the best for our viewers
what else do we have
here's another i just have backup
streams upon backup streams because we
always want to have them
we are also standing by for joseph r
biden jr i'm going to give you
my updated map with likely and solid
colors it's going to be really an
incredible day
and this is it guys it could go either
way
um we are now only 20
hold on 25 hours and 47 minutes 25
47 from getting the first closures
in states as well as the first early
results and remember
we never have by the way what is on
screen we we do not have 151 people who
signed up i forgot to get us
ourselves reset from yesterday there we
go we never have full results on
election night
don't let them trick you we never do uh
networks make calls based on
demographics exit polls party
registration
it is always an estimate and um
i understand everybody being nervous but
it is going to be it's going to be okay
is my prediction all right just make
sure that you know you have a backup
plan is all i'm saying
but uh we we are going to be following
it all very closely i will be going live
at 7 00 pm eastern tomorrow evening
and by the way we already have a where
is it hold on
we already have a live event scheduled
here
and um you can rsvp even if you plan to
watch on twitch
facebook or not at all i'm gonna paste
the link here
a few times in a youtube chat
and a few times in twitch chat it would
really help us
algorithmically you understand what i'm
saying if you hit
set reminder on that event because then
you're telling youtube you're interested
which makes youtube think people are
interested which is of course a lie
but we want the algorithm to tell more
people hey here's a place you could
watch election results tomorrow night
so please hit that set reminder button
um it looks like right now only 45
people have we actually can see it go up
in real time but that'll be tomorrow
night
and i think it'll be a really really
great event um
for all of us and hopefully it will be
one that ends
without crying without crying is
certainly what we want at the end of the
night tomorrow night
um axios with an exclusive report today
that donald trump's plan is to declare
victory
that's the plan now you might say well
hold on in an election
doesn't it matter who votes for whom and
in a normal situation the answer would
be yes but trump's plan is to declare
victory tomorrow night
in any situation other than a biden
blowout if it's a biden blowout trump
can't declare victory probably
but he will then say oh we've got to
wait for all the votes if it's
close if trump has a plausible small
lead in states even if many votes remain
to be counted
uh trump is going to declare victory he
has canceled his victory party at his
hotel in dc
and instead is going to be staying at
the white house behind
a new supposedly unscalable fence
and that is where trump will be tomorrow
night so that's the plan
we know what to expect now in the
meantime
we have at last count another
70 000 coronavirus cases today
led by illinois florida kansas
wisconsin and michigan we have the
latest
vote counts with 97.6 million
people total voting we already have 100
million votes
if you look at some states in texas
eight percent more people have already
voted
than the total from 2016. in
hawaii 110 of the 2016 turnout has
already voted
where else is strong montana 99
jersey 88 florida 94
north carolina 95. arizona 93.
i don't know of any way that these
numbers are good for trump it doesn't
mean he will lose
i just don't think these numbers are
good for donald trump and we're going to
continue
tracking all of those numbers as you can
imagine as you can imagine we will be
tracking
absolutely all of it um
okay let's get into some of the meat
oh do people want a new song i just just
for something light i do have an
actually i have two songs
so yesterday i debuted the new single
from jethro bradley
suppression balls uh let me just remind
you of suppression balls we need a
little bit of a comedic interlude they
want to go out and they want to touch
they want to vote
i'm working my ass off here i'm soaking
wet already
soaking wet soaking wet already
suppression falls yesterday we had three
big ones really big
suppression balls you don't give me the
umbrella i'm soaking wet already
they put numbers you know they're called
suppression suppression balls
they make you like feel badly so you
said to your wife you said your husband
darling let's go out to dinner and then
we'll come back we love our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
whoa sorry about that
okay so that's suppression balls here's
a new one fresh uh fresh off the uh
i guess you know audacity i don't know
um garageband here is jethro bradley's
song
for kamala and i i know it's kamala but
this is song for kamala you will
understand
by david jones is his running mate the
most liberal senator in america kamala
senator kamala harris
that's killer democrat kamala
that's huge you have a pre-existing
condition heart disease
diabetes breast cancer their common fear
basis killer if you love someone who has
a pregnancy word has it that friend of
the show
stu basie brooks look him up big friend
of the show good friend of mine
he is impressed with the base here thank
you
come here
i want to just first of all say i'm so
excited to be here
thank you thank you thank you there is
so much about what comes out of donald
trump's mouth
don't be rude that is designed to
distract the american people
from what he is doing every day that is
about neglect
negligence and harmony i think
after um all this is over if we go back
to doing live events
we will have a soundtrack like that will
play before you know like if the plan
for anna casparian and i to do some live
events gets put back together after the
the virus
this is gonna have to be the playlist
for the pre-show here's one other one
this is called somewhat of a problem
this is by
house news 10.
new revelations about when and what
president trump allegedly knew about the
coronavirus
according to a new book by bob woodward
we have a totally under control one
person
coming in from china we only have five
people hopefully everything's going to
be great
they have somewhat of a problem but
hopefully it's all going to be great
and again when you have 15 people the 15
within a couple of days is going to be
down to close to zero uh
that's a pretty good job we've done well
i think bob really
to be honest with you sure i want you to
i wanted to
uh i wanted to always play it down i
still like playing it down
because i don't want to create a panic
staring down the barrel of the derringer
riots in the cities and a variant
prepare for it anyway it's a bit more of
a downer but i think we'll look i think
it will be nostalgic if uh indeed
we succeed in removing the mango menace
so i think that that's what we have
to look forward to there the songs are
incredible they really are and then just
as a very very quick
quick reminder just because we have the
time we do have joe woodward's uh
anthemic tracks including maybe most
powerfully david pakman is a beta male
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive
host an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program
the david pacman show and i wanted to
talk to david patman
he is a band anyway you guys know that
that's that's pretty high quality stuff
there so
um we have plenty of music and i think
you know depending on the results
tomorrow we may even go in with with
some of those tomorrow
okay i want to get to super chats i want
to get to twitch messages i want to get
to all of it very soon but first let me
just get caught up on
people i owe a thank you to okay because
there are already certain people
raul rodriguez is new member number one
today
aiden swann is new member number two
marcelo diaz dos santos is new member
number three
and samuel powell is new member number
four also
we are counting twitch subs we're
throwing it all at the wall to see what
sticks
and we are we went from 1200
to 1207 which okay 1207 minus 1200
1 minus 1 is zero 2 minus 2 is zero
zero minus zero zero zero seven okay
that's seven more that puts us
at 11 out of one hundred very nice and i
will open phone lines again
we had some beautiful phone calls
yesterday actually uh we will open phone
lines again if indeed we get to 100.
okay other super chats coming in let's
start with super chats
dr chakaseki from the david pakman show
radiology department
says someone sent me a video of
trumpkins at a lancaster event doing a
literal covet conga line
chanting four more years the death cult
is dancing off the cliff they i i hope
so
adam williams is very much a shame that
these two came to traverse city we are
liberals here
go away fascists powerful
amy says i'm a lefty in rural or rural
as some say
rural louisiana deep in trump country i
didn't put up a campaign sign for biden
because i was genuinely afraid
this election is volatile i hope that my
perception of the violence to come is an
overreaction
i hope so too amy i'm gonna have a very
important statement tomorrow about the
violent stuff
um on tomorrow we i've already i've been
i spent
we filmed early today because i really
wanted time to think about what i want
to say in the last podcast
before the election tomorrow and i will
be speaking about the potential for
violence for sure
sam dean says g'day mate from australia
genuine question what is one of the most
embarrassing things the trump
administration has done so far in your
opinion
please don't say everything i'm an
australian i mean listen
just to pick something because it's
fresh in my mind okay just something
do you guys remember this remember when
a a
a weather forecast did not align with
what donald trump wanted
and so with a sharpie a different
track for the hurricane was drawn just
with a sharpie
this is just an example because this was
fresh on my mind i tweeted this one
today
here's just one example okay and because
to avoid saying everything that's just
one example as you asked for um
let's see we're still standing by for
donald trump in traverse city michigan
ken says trump is acting like a casino
owner who always wants the house edge oh
that's right
he is a casino owner and an ineffective
one at that
well said hi david love your channel
best of luck tomorrow thank you
emmanuel kant says there has just been
an anti-semitic attack in austria our
thoughts are with the austrian people
of course i haven't heard about it but
of course that's ghastly says a friend
is dropping off his ballot
at the poll because he thinks the postal
service workers are modifying ballots by
steaming
opening copying and resealing them
that's not an effective wholesale
strategy because that takes a long time
but i think it's a great idea to drop
off ballots i think it's a great idea at
this point
ant and sharon say hey david we're
worried about trump stealing the
election and screwing us
all great song inconsolable says you
seem to be in good spirits despite the
circumstances my mom is so stressed i'm
legitimately concerned about her
physical health
i'm concerned about a lot of people's
physical health i'm not going to lie
but i think this is really a time where
we have to apply the tenants not the
tenants by the way
i recently saw someone do that again
saying the tenants
it's like tenants are people who rent an
apartment okay
um tenants is the word the tenants of
stoicism
did we vote i hope the answer is yeah
great did we express to others
that they should vote and who they
should vote for um
we we've really we can only each do so
much and at a certain point we have to
uh separate ourselves from the outcome
and say did we do what we could do
and i feel like we have i've been saying
we've got to vote for about two years
now
um okay other uh super chats coming in
gaelic dream says people talk about shy
trump voters but what about shy biden
voters like my mom
who comes from a conservative family shy
voters aren't always for trump
yeah i mean it's it's and if someone
says shy voters exist
and polls can't possibly account for
them then polls can't account for them
and we just all have to vote and on that
note do you guys want to see my my
latest map
uh i could do my latest map if you want
want to say thanks to
vani davis who's new member number 12
today at joinpackman.com
also six additional twitch
subs puts us at 18.
all right let's do the map now i'm going
to recreate it i'm not like i actually
like to talk through it with you guys
so i'm going to talk through it right
now one of the things i'm i'm doing now
is i'm doing safe and lean and the
reason i'm doing safe and lean
is i want to be able to categorize
strong
biden and trump votes and then lean
biden and trump votes so let's just get
to it
washington is solid blue oregon solid
blue or oregon
and california solid blue alaska is
solid red
hawaii is solid blue montana solid red
idaho
solid red wyoming solid red utah solid
red colorado solid blue
new mexico solid blue dakotas red
nebraska red kansas red oklahoma red
minnesota i have a solid blue i know
trump is saying he has a shot i don't
believe he does
uh missouri is solid red arkansas
louisiana
mississippi alabama tennessee kentucky
indiana west virginia south carolina
all solid red my friends
vermont is solid blue new hampshire is
going blue
massachusetts of course all of this
stuff all of this stuff is going blue
no doubt about it uh maine
i am putting a solid blue i'm sort of
like
willing to say that the second district
is leaning blue
that's as far as i'm i'm looking to go
okay
new york of course solid solid blue
i believe wisconsin is solid blue
but i believe michigan is leaning blue
i believe pennsylvania is not solid but
leaning blue i think florida
is leaning red i think texas is leaning
red i know that there's questions about
these and i think georgia is leaning red
virginia will be strongly blue
north carolina is leaning blue
ohio leaning red iowa i think is leaning
but not necessarily red
illinois is going to be blue i do think
that the second district in nebraska
could go blue so i'm calling it leaning
red nevada leaning blue
and arizona i believe is leaning blue
so this is my map now importantly
hold on am i missing trump i'm not okay
important about this
first let's look at what's solid i don't
think there's
any scenario where joe biden gets fewer
than 236 electoral votes
i don't think they're i think 236 boom
is
solid for biden and i think trump gets
himself
125. that's that's solid safe
safe blue safe red you then have
69 electoral votes that are
leaning biden and 108 electoral votes
that are leaning trump now
of course if trump gets himself
all of these that are leaning red
uh he still only has 233
okay so let's give trump everything
that's leaning red
red red red red red we'll give him
nebraska
and that's good okay we give trump
everything leaning red he's got 233
so he needs to take something
from this 69 okay who could imagine it
would come down
to 69 but it does so of course
you know if donald trump can take
michigan
and pennsylvania we have that tie
scenario
um if he can take that one main
district he gets 270 to 268. i do think
that that is likely
uh still leaning blue um other scenarios
would be
you know if he doesn't get michigan or
um he needs to get nevada
and arizona and north whoops no i didn't
want to go
hold on things going astray here
virginia will be blue
and north carolina this would be a
scenario that gets him close but it's
still not enough
so the point here is
biden can just win with safe
and leans democratic trump can't win
with safe and leans republican trump
needs to take something from joe biden
if you if you push me and say what would
that be
um i think michigan is is something it
could be
and the reason i say that is if we look
at the michigan polling
uh and then we'll get off of this even
though joe biden is winning michigan
much like he's winning wisconsin
the trend in michigan favors trump and
this is what we had in 2016.
in 2016 in pennsylvania
wisconsin and michigan if there had been
seven more days of polling it's
perfectly reasonable to expect that
those states would have started polling
in favor of trump
the late comey perversion um
started a swing in trump's direction the
polling
ran out of time if you had polled people
the two days before the election
and given us those numbers the day after
the election
it's very likely that trump could have
been tied her ahead
trump has that momentum in michigan
which is why when i look at the map
if you say from wisconsin michigan and
pennsylvania what's the most likely
thing to go
trump for me it's michigan okay
uh so this is this is sort of where uh
now we've gotten off of my original map
i'm not gonna recreate it now because it
would take too long
but um that's where we are now one other
thing that's
really excellent um producer pat sent me
this today
okay this is brilliant this is
given that a candidate wins or loses a
certain state
what happens to the odds so let me give
you an example
okay uh in general you know the odds
right now
are that trump has a 10 chance of
winning if joe biden were to come out
powerfully ahead in north carolina okay
so we set north carolina to biden
if that happens biden would have a
greater than 99
chance of winning the entire thing this
is if
biden wins north carolina which we might
know early now if
trump wins north carolina trump's
chances go from 10 to 27
this is a very very interesting map and
you can do it in combination so we were
looking at my map here
you know what happens if trump wins
michigan if trump were to win michigan
because it would require a reversal in
the polls
if trump gets michigan his odds of
winning
go from 10 to 85. why because like i
said
if he's able to reverse the polling it
would signal
a shift in trump's direction so play
around with this this is very very
interesting
just to pick something else i mean just
to give you a sense of the importance of
florida
if trump wins florida his odds go from
10 to 32.
if biden were to win florida there's a
greater than 99
chance biden wins now unfortunately as i
mentioned on yesterday's stream
what i'm hearing from my contacts in
florida
it's not it's not the best it's not the
best my i increasingly think that joe
biden
has a far greater shot of winning north
carolina
and pennsylvania than if north carolina
and orr i'm not saying both but i think
biden has a bigger chance of winning
north carolina than he does florida
and i think biden has a bigger chance of
winning pennsylvania than he does
florida
and and case in point one last thing um
if you look at pennsylvania
if trump gets pennsylvania his odds
go wait no this doesn't make any sense
oh i have to undo florida there we go
if trump gets pennsylvania his odds go
to 61
if biden gets pennsylvania he goes to 99
and this gets us to the importance
because what happens is these are
if biden gets pennsylvania there's few
scenarios that have trump winning like
there's this one
276 to 262 scenario so play around with
this this is this is a very very
important uh
important thing okay we're getting ready
to hear from donald trump
please do me a favor i have already set
up this event
for tomorrow's live stream okay
please i'm pasting the link in youtube
chat a few times
and in twitch chat a few times please
get in there
and hit reminder say set reminder
doing that signals to youtube very
strongly that you're interested in
watching on my channel
even if you don't plan plan to okay even
if you plan to watch
you know steven crowder give you the
results or whatever
just do that because that actually does
help us and it would be a really really
great thing
okay what else do we have let me now get
to
let me get caught up on thank yous i
want to say thanks to
alejandro battis who is new member
number 19
kath silversides is number 20 and rimond
cd is new member number 21.
as i mentioned earlier twitch subs count
today
and we have one more on twitch
which puts us at 22 as we are waiting
for donald trump i don't know if they're
keeping oh trump just landed okay
there is trump and let's listen to joe
biden briefly
and frank o'hara's came because guess
what happened
the rooney's really fine fine people
the rooneys decided that they were going
to send
rocky and franco
to see my boys no publicity
they didn't do any press didn't let
anybody know
they spent 45 minutes with my boys they
got in the plane and went home
that's who we are as a country
that's something the president doesn't
understand
looking out for each other the thousand
acts of kindness
the decency that people used to show to
one another
and still do that he just doesn't get
pittsburgh pittsburgh there's one more
day
one more day to show who we are once
again
tomorrow we can end the presidency that
has divided this nation
folks at home would know tomorrow we can
put an end to a presidency that's failed
to protect the nation
tomorrow we can put an end to a
presidency that has fanned the flames of
hate
across this nation pouring gasoline on
every racial incident in the country
millions of americans have already voted
over almost 100 million now
millions more will vote tomorrow my
message is simple
the power to change this country is in
your hands
and i don't care how hard donald trump
tries
there's nothing nothing he can do to
stop the people this nation
from voting no matter how he tries let's
hope
there's a press article last week
and it read as follows never before
in modern presidential history has a
candidate
been so reliant on wide-scale efforts to
repress the vote
as trump doesn't want y'all voting
he don't want americans voting he thinks
only wealthy folks should vote
and when america votes though america
will be heard
when america's heard the message is
going to be out loud and clear
it's time for donald trump to pack his
bags
and go home go home
look we're done with the chaos
we're done with the racism we're done
with the tweets the anger the hate
the failure the irresponsibility but we
got a lot of work to do folks
if i'm elected president we're gonna act
on day one we're gonna act to get covert
under control
on day one of my presidency i'll put an
action a plan
that i've been talking about for months
masking social discipline testing
tracing
a plan for full and fair and free
distribution of therapeutics and
vaccines
when we get one and most importantly we
hadn't done yet a plan
a plan that addresses the fact that we
can
get everybody access to the vaccine when
it comes
folks there's over 300 million people in
america
everyone everyone
is going to get help the plan to address
the disproportionate way
the virus is heading the black community
and minority communities
we're seeing race-based disparities all
across every aspect of this virus
higher infection rates lower access to
testing
yeah this is ma everybody's picking this
is our favorite uh sign language
interpreter
he is uh tran i guess tr is a translator
or interpreter
um this is this is by far our favorite
guy
higher mortality rates three times as
high
as the white population one
in one thousand black americans have
died from covid
so far and by the end of this pandemic
if things continue as he's allowing them
do until the next president takes office
there will be another two hundred 000
deaths projected
and that'll mean one in
500 african-americans so there's a
little bit of joe biden we're going to
listen to a little bit of donald trump
i hope to hear from you guys now i'm
realizing there's something a little
tricky going on i said that
to open the phone lines we're counting
twitch subs we have this unfortunate
situation
where we are losing subscribers because
there's a lot of these autumn these a
lot of twitch subs are just for a month
the twitch prime ones
and it just so happens because this is a
normal time that i stream that everybody
who signed up a month ago
the numbers are decreasing which is
really sad to see
but i want to make sure i don't miss
anybody so i think that we actually have
two more
um and the last one was don't be
yourself be better so that actually puts
us
at 24. uh don't i want to make sure
everybody absolutely
counts and then a few
other super chats that i want oh and i'm
sorry and also chris lingo chris lingo
is uh new member number 25 today um so
everybody will count and i will open
phone lines and at this point as you
know
we're listening to a little bit of biden
we're going to listen to a little bit of
trump these rallies are all the same
it's more about you know having the
community here and hearing from you guys
hearing what's on everybody's minds and
that's that sort of thing so now by the
way
we will be counting memberships that
arrive after november 3rd this is
actually potentially because
of the 60 this is a good question from
twitch chat because the 66
discount is illegal in some of the
states where it's legal to marry your
cousin
there is a lot of stuff caught up in the
courts right now
and even if your membership arrives
after november 3rd we are counting
all memberships regardless of coupon
code regardless of platform
they are we're counting them all and you
know william barr can go to hell i don't
care what he says
it's all counting um and that's that's
extremely exciting
okay a few other oh this is important
bearded bullets
says imagine spending three and a half
years studying a subject only to realize
there's a large portion of the
population that ignores the most basic
concepts they're in
it is literally maddening yeah you know
i was actually pretty depressed last
week when
we got these gdp numbers oh gdp up 33
or whatever and you know in my story
this is a channel that's mostly adults
like there's not really kids
when i and i'm not bragging when i and
many other people
were 10 we understood if you start with
100 if you lose 50
you then need to gain 100 to get back to
a hundred
okay simple concept on rates of change
um
i was ex i did a segment where you would
think in other countries like
if in japan uh in
israel in sweden you know if they saw
the clip i did last week where i go
hey guys we lost 31 gdp
and then we gained 33 but those are
monthly
quarterly numbers that were annualized
and these are rates of change you have
to go changes the denominator
they would have thought this program was
for middle school
i i had i i have no other way to say it
they would have thought if you see in
other countries if you see me putting up
the chart i put up
that's like 100 minus 31 is 69 plus 33
percent
is only 92 so down 31 plus 33 you're
still down eight
you would imagine this is a channel
meant to teach uh 10 11 12 year olds
simple math um and that's unfortunately
the situation in which we find ourselves
right now it's a disaster
did i get it i get it it's a complete
and total disaster
um okay other super chats paul says
wondering how much negative press cobb
fefe there will be tomorrow and if nars
will be mentioned
one who knows who knows i hope you will
all join me tomorrow night
kyle says a judge ruled in las vegas
that polling procedures will not change
after attempts have been made by the
trump reelection campaign now trump will
likely sue clark county if it goes blue
speaking of which uh producer pat
put together a v i'm not kidding here
a very powerful document called
bellwether counties there are a bunch of
counties that almost always the winner
of these counties wins the presidency so
let me give you an example okay vigo
indiana since hold on since what year
since 1888 only twice
has vigo county not voted for the
eventual winner of the presidency
okay they missed it in 1908 and 1952.
since 56 vigo county is perfect
in that the national results go with
what happens in vigo county
correlation is not causation
all that stuff but we're going to be
tracking this let me give you another
example
um what's another good one uh let's see
here an interesting one okay
uh essex virginia essex county virginia
since 1948 only once
has essex virginia not voted
for the winning candidate so
individually these are just
correlations but if tomorrow we look at
for example the 11 counties with only
one miss
and one candidate has eight of them
early
that certainly is something that would
give us an idea of the way that the
night is going and by the way north
carolina at 7 45
will probably also give us an idea of
the direction that things are going
uh okay other super chats coming in
let's see sabrina says david thanks for
the great time last night
wow oh my god that's that's aggressive
devorah says
generation z any opinions on the u.s
political impact in the next decade or
so
let's deal with that that's a that's a
post-election question that's a
post-election question
sen by the way what is going on here
is is this trump's plane that is here or
or is this pence's plane to take him out
does anybody know what's going on
because i'm actually not understanding
what's happening right now
anybody know let's listen
oh my god um
okay well we're listening to it all
and me and by the way does anybody want
to hear a little bit more of joe biden
what do you guys think or do
have we heard enough and now we'll just
wait for a little bit of trump i just
don't understand why the plane is in the
dark i really don't
anybody any ideas
a little more biden maybe no biden
people don't want biden wait for trump
oh it's dark because it's night time i
didn't understand oh
i'm sorry thanks guys thanks i didn't
really understand that all right let's
do like five more minutes of biden
and then when i got elected vice
president said it's probable
no man has ever assumed the office vice
president with fewer assets than joe
biden
i assume they weren't speaking about
intellectual assets
it could have been but who knows but
look here's my point
trump and the only taxes that we've been
able to find out through the new york
times
the one year he has he paid 750
in taxes right trump keeps talking about
corruption
when's the last time he heard of a
president having a secret
bank account in china
which he did we just found out where he
played
50 times more tax in china
than he did in the united states
every time he starts talking about
corruption i say
release your tax return what in the hell
are you hiding
what are you hiding not one
anyway i won't get into it look
we're gonna act no no no joke one of my
favorite things about biden
is when he decides to get away from like
a direction that he's going
and he talks himself out of it i love it
for some reason
well if they get their way 100 million
americans
will lose the protections for
pre-existing conditions
including more than 5 million people
here in the united states
i mean excuse me here in the state of
pennsylvania
over 100 million in the united states
millions of black americans will be left
uninsured denied health coverage
because of pre-existing conditions and
there are more pre-existing conditions
in poorer communities
than there are in others donald trump
thinks health care is a privilege
i think it's a right
look i'll not only restore it for
obamacare i'll build on it
you can keep your private insurance if
you like it you can choose medicare like
public option i'm going to increase
subsidies to lower your premiums
deductibles out-of-pocket expenses
out-of-pocket spending
surprise billing i'm going to lower
prescription drugs by 60
and that's the truth but by the way how
you gonna do it joe
because those wealthy people are gonna
start paying their fair share
it's not about punishing everyone it's
about being fair
we'll make sure the protections for
people with pre-existing conditions
remain
and meanwhile trump said publicly said
if he's re-elected
he's going to defund social security
payments
actuary and social security department
said if he does that
that will eliminate eliminate
medicare by 2023
after all the people rely on medicare
it's not going to happen by the way
we're not going to let it happen
but that's his plan so go home and tell
your grandparents and parents
will protect social security medicare
and medicaid which he won't do
and finally vote deliver some we need a
vote now
to deliver some racial justice in
america
look a season of protest has broken out
all across this nation
protesting is not burning alluded in
violence that can't be tolerated in a
woe but
those protests are cry for justice
in the name of george floyd brianna
taylor
jacob blake walter wallace jr
they're not going to be forgotten
they're not going to be forgotten by me
not by us not by this country they'll
inspire a whole new wave of justice in
america
when i met with when i met with floyd's
family
as a little daughter survived him she's
six years old
and i knelt down i talked to her i said
i started to talk to her
you know what she said she looked at me
said mr vice president
all right we are getting very close to
the start of the trump
event uh we are going to be opening the
phone lines
if we get to 100 new members and twitch
subs
and we're i think we're getting close
i'm going to run the numbers in a second
but i think we've just had about 40
people drop in via twitch
um i really would love it if you grabbed
a membership at joinedpakman.com we've
the last few weeks actually a lot of
people have written to me saying david
i've got to cancel because
of what's going on financially going
into the second wave uh
people getting reduced hours businesses
uh slowing down
in some of the most affected states and
i totally get that
uh so in order to sort of counterbalance
some of these
understandable cancellations i would
love it if you had a couple bucks a
month grab a membership at
joinpackman.com the coupon code above my
head
goes away tomorrow the coupon code is
over we've got to destroy the evidence
from these illegal discounts
so tomorrow what would the election we
will be ending the discount
2020 now take advantage of it grab it
and then if we do get to 100 um i'll
even interrupt the trump rally because
like we know what he's gonna say
you know it's always the same same crap
different day
uh we will we will strongly open the
phone lines and i look forward to
hearing from you guys let's see what's
happening here
oh perfect timing
thank huh oh wow
this is a big crowd we have a lot of big
crowds but this is a big fan
the hat is so stupid i mean it's just so
dumb
hello traverse city hello michigan
we want the same result as we had
four years ago from michigan
that we don't fulfilled all our promises
you have auto plants so many
you didn't have one in 42 years and now
you have 17.
those are lies going up and they're
going so fast i don't know
that's just a flat out lie i can tell
you that but
we want that same result we're going to
get out and vote because
tomorrow we are going to win the state
and we are going to
win four more years in the white house
and i want to thank you to our great
vice president mike pence
he works so hard i will take him over
kamala everybody again with the kamala
i will take we will take mike he's great
he's great he's done a great job
he works very hard and he had a good
debate didn't he have a good debate
against kamala
yeah the fly one from a different world
with your vote we will continue to cut
your taxes cut
regulations support our police support
our great military protect
our second amendment defend religious
liberty
and ensure more products are proudly
stamped with that beautiful term
made in the usa right
right next year
will be the greatest economic year in
the history of our country you know you
had
with him gone let's hope last year the
year before the year before three great
years
the best you've ever had and you're
gonna have the best year you ever
had next year we're all set you saw what
happened
under my leadership our economy is now
growing at the fastest rate
ever ever ever recorded 33 that's that
stupid math we were just talking about
on friday we created a record 11.4
million jobs in the last five months
that's a record
while foreign nations are in a free fall
sadly in a free fall you look at what's
happening with europe and
trump said yeah it's very sad we are
creating an economic powerhouse
unrivaled anywhere in the world you look
at our numbers look at the auto numbers
look at what's happening with
that business and uh so many other
businesses in this country but that
business because we happen to be in a
place that likes automobiles right
a recep gallup poll just came out
gala 56 of americans say they are better
off today than they were
four years ago under obama and biden
and that's during a pandemic and we're
rounding the corner
we're rounding the corner and you gotta
open your states
you gotta open your state open it open
it up governor
open it up governor right open it up
governor
we've got to open it up if biden and
harris
the radical left gain power they will
collapse our economy and send our nation
into a very steep depression
they want to raise taxes at a level that
nobody's ever heard of before
biden will raise your taxes over four
trillion dollars
man it's not him do you think it's him
he doesn't have a clue
there's the biden dementia stuff but
that's okay let's assume he does we have
to win
so that's it can't do that to our
country our country has too much
unbelievable potential actually
massively increasing your
regulations shutting down your economy
they're going to close down your
factories send your jobs overseas to
china and other places i don't think so
destroy the suburbs are you happy in the
suburbs that i ended the regulation that
was going to destroy the suburbs and has
been destroyed this summer
the women of the suburbs they love me i
think but you know the
fake news says they don't but i think
they do
they love their home they love their
house
they don't want a development put next
to their house
what he means is black people guys
it's a euphemism for black people i
think they like trump i really do that
happened the last time
that happened four years ago remember
they said women will not
vote for donald trump at that time
women will not and then at the end of
the evening when they're all crying
they say women what happened the women
came out right
where women the women liked us
that's nice well i like the women i will
tell you i think the women are great
there you go you notice we don't even
talk about the men with suburbia we let
you guys be alive
they want to dissolve your borders maybe
rip down the wall they were talking
about that let's take down the wall
you know we have our strongest border
right now and the wall is almost
complete
almost complete that's the lie that's a
second lie
terminate religious liberty outlaw
private healthcare 180 million people
they want to take it away go to
socialize
imagine thinking biden wants to outlaw
private health care
there's people on the left who are
furious that biden doesn't want to do
that
and trump's saying that's what he wants
to do private plans
take it away now if you feel a little
bad or if you want to check up you go to
a
hospital you wait online for about six
weeks and
you get yourself checked out if they say
you have a problem they can't do
anything about it that's called
socialized medicine
trump has no idea how hospitals
and indoctrinate your children with
anti-american lies
and just a little while ago on the
beautiful air force one how does it look
by the way how about this guy
vote trump because of sunsets let's just
look at the sky for a little while
i wish we had time right i wish we had
time
so uh you know i've made would do five
today five of these
all with love all with big crowds always
yeah by the way
six week weights aren't that rare for
specialists now and there's no socialism
it's weird
they said i actually do six today
because we finished up last night in
miami at 1
30 in the morning so thank you
oh thank you very much
you know they've never chanted that
before nobody's ever chanted that before
don't see if he does that you know i
started to cry they'd have a big story
they'd say
the president broke down and cried
and i don't know if that's good for us
probably could
maybe it brings me up four or five
points i promise huh
i don't care but that's really nice you
know it's never been said before they
say there it is
it's an incredible thing we've worked
hard we've gotten everything we said
we've done
the things we said we've done the things
we said we get you the biggest tax cut
in history the biggest regulation cut in
history what happened to that health
care plan that was two weeks away from
becoming law by the way
percent approval rating on what we've
had today
we've got you space force and you'll be
making a lot of this stuff right here in
michigan face space is the first that is
the first time in 74 years since
air force think of that right a whole
new force
i just signed an executive order on air
force one to teach our students
pro-american values important stuff guys
that he's signing there
more like air farce one of the things
that i've been watching that have been
taking place over a
pretty long period of time a pretty long
period of time even before obama and
sleepy joe
biden has vowed to abolish the american
oil and natural
gas industries and to ban fracking look
he said it
he said it he campaigned for over a year
i wish he would phase out fracking
that'd be great
we will ban frank and then he goes to
pennsylvania
and they say well you know his people
told him
he didn't have any idea what that meant
but it was okay he listened to him
they said listen you have to be in favor
of fracking now
he said okay no problem why i only said
it about 200 times during debates right
so they've been so now he goes into
pennsylvania where we just left
great people by the way you talk about
that was a
an unbelievably enthusiastic group of
people we're gonna win pennsylvania
we're gonna right
we're gonna win guess we'll see
we're going to win pennsylvania we won
pennsylvania last time too we won this
one we won
this one hadn't been won for many many
years and
pennsylvania the same thing it wouldn't
but then trump came along we went
about we beat crooked hillary crook and
hillary
will he talk about her emails again now
we have a guy that makes hillary look
like a baby
we had some we've had a good time and
until the
chinese until the china plague came
along
everything was good we closed it down we
saved two million
they said sir you've tested positive for
the china plague
see the hat all the make america great
again now we're having it
make america great again again you know
and our country was coming together you
know the other side was calling
everybody was successful right numbers
for unemployment african-american
hispanic-american
and by the way do you see what's going
on inuit american
african-american the numbers are
phenomenal hispanic-american
the numbers are beyond the arab american
they got problems you notice they
haven't been talking too much about
florida for the last uh
six or seven hours they're not liking
what they see
they're not wow that is a lot of people
look you can't even see why don't you
take the camera turn the cameras turn
the camera
see the end i hope you can hear us down
there
it's like two football fields away i
hope you can hear us football
that's great well that's really good but
uh no florida's looking great
you're looking great came out too i do
think
trump will end up with florida i i do
think that i don't think he's wrong and
he may have gotten some of that same
information that started to spread about
florida early voting
we won't even talk about it but you're
looking great north carolina great
iowa came out the big poll came out
yesterday you saw huge poll
and we were a lot up big big up where
the farmers like me we're big up
i got for the farmers 28 billion dollars
i got 28 billion from china thank you
very much china
socialism wow because they targeted the
farmers
they targeted the farmers and i said to
sonny perdue secretary of
give him money how much he said well two
years ago was 12
and last year was 16 billion 16 billion
12 billion
a total of 28 billion given the cash
we had a lot of money left over into the
treasury
and we gave it to the farmers and the
farmers are not complaining i'll tell
you
wow you gave people money and they
accepted it shocking stuff huh biden's
energy ban
will send every state into crushing
poverty
and you know this you know what they're
doing from michigan
to wisconsin to arizona where we're
leading very nicely thank you
and to pennsylvania as long as i'm
president is there any state trump would
admit he's losing in or does he just not
mention those states
on earth and we
will remain energy independent we're
energy independent for the first time
first time that means we don't have to
call people up
in far away places and say we need some
oil please we'll send our armies over
there to
protect you and help you but we do have
great allies over there well
what is the latest arizona data by the
way here
good people over there we'll help them
but we don't need their oil it's nice
not to need we have more oil than they
do
now you know we have actually more it's
tight we're the largest in the world
sleepy joe and that would not have
happened except for what we've done over
the last three and a half years there's
never been an administration or
president
there's never been an administration
that has done
in the first three and a half years what
we've done never and not even twice
most people would never think of doing
the things trump's done because they're
all horribly immoral
and the fake news never even questions
that i've been saying it for a long time
they don't even question it because they
can't
joe biden is a globalist who spent 47
years
uh-oh outsourcing your jobs opening your
borders
and sacrificing american blood and
treasure
in endless ridiculous foreign wars
countries you never even heard of a vote
for biden is a vote to extinguish
and eradicate your state's auto industry
you don't like that do you i don't think
so
so far i guess these used euphemisms for
minorities
and for jews right uh people who will
live in developments that they build in
the suburbs like that's code for
you know black and brown people
globalist even if he doesn't know it has
historically been a way to
conspiracize about jews am i missing
anything so far
it's probably the number one reason i
ran for president
and in fact i was in michigan i don't
know if anybody remembers this 12 years
ago they gave me the man of the year you
remember
and i had a big i made a speech and i
said why are you letting you understand
my business but i said why are you
letting them
steal your auto jobs they're all going
down to mexico by the way plenty go to
canada too right
people don't know that and it was a
terrible thing that took place but we've
stopped that and now the usmca makes it
very very financially difficult
for them to do that it was very
important to me
and everybody said we'll never be able
to do it we'll never be able to
end nafta and you know why because it
was so good for canada
i'm i'm sure most of you know that usmca
is not dramatically different than nafta
and that the issue of trade i said this
yesterday i can't help but try to
you know give people information the
issue of trade is far more complicated
than donald trump wants to wants to
account for
and generally speaking a trade is good
for countries
it's particularly good for smaller
countries than bigger countries the u.s
is big enough that we could
manufacture most stuff ourselves
but you'd still in many cases need to
import
certain raw materials we would
probably have a small but the point is
if we stop
trading because we tariff everybody so
much because we're big and strong
we would have a small reduction to gdp
but it would be a reorganization where
we would have to accept that many of our
things would
just be more expensive and our entire
economy is based around
let's get cheap stuff from china that's
the the
genesis of where we are today started
with that idea
anyway what am i even who am i talking
to here
sleepy joe supported china's entry into
the
wto michigan lost half of all auto
manufacturing jobs
after those binding betrayals he also
supported the trans-pacific partnership
which would have been the death sentence
for the u.s auto industry
i canceled tpp i ended the nafta
disaster
and i took the toughest action ever
taken against
china we never took in 10 cents on china
i've taken in
billions and billions of dollars over
the last two years
this is another example if you put a 10
percent tariff on chinese steel
the american company pays china for the
steel
and pays the treasury for the tariff now
there are those who will say well
china will have to reduce the price of
steel by 10
so china loses the 10 and worst case
the business is even that takes time and
it doesn't apply when it's difficult to
change supply lines but again
look who i'm arguing against the guy who
called michael flynn in the middle of
the night and said
is a strong dollar good or bad for us
mike that's who i'm talking to about
trade
we were just beginning and not only with
china
with everyone else that takes advantage
of our country
dear god
thank you very much no but with
everybody else it takes
it's not only john it's everybody we
renegotiated the
south korea deal you know that that was
a deal crooked hillary made that deal it
was going to give
250 thousand jobs she was talking this
will produce 250
000 jobs they signed it and she ended up
being correct
but the 250 000 jobs all went to south
korea not to us
that was standard that was standard it's
funny when people nod as if they've
ever heard of these anecdotes before
decrepit and depraved political crash
they got rich bleeding
america dry and you know what happened
there haven't been too many states that
have been affected like you've been
affected
you got seriously affected
are they chanting yankees suck
bring your socks what are they saying
we're doing it
we're doing it but when i ran you never
told drain the swamp oh oh my god
vicious that rock it's a deep sucker i
thought would knock it out fast
sucker we went through three and a half
years of hell
and here we are and they're not too
happy and they're they're reeling
they're reeling they're going to be
knocked off very soon they're going to
be all knocked off
knocked off by the way i see people
asking for mercy bands you don't really
need a nursing
mercy band today because we're just
three members or twitch subs from
opening phone lines
and then we can just watch and i'll talk
to you guys about what's on your minds
and today was very very special of event
where
not only does signing up at
joinpackman.com move the bar closer to
100
even just normal twitch subs and twitch
prime subs they all count
uh so we i'm glad to end that believe me
it's not like i want to hear another one
of these
go up and they say let's impeach him
i'll tell you
and we had great support from the
republican party i have to say that 197
to nothing in that
52 and a half to one half you know the
half was
that's right we had 52 and a half to one
half
mitt romney
he still doesn't know why say let's see
why did i do that
he wished he didn't do it i'll tell you
that in 2016 michigan voted to
fire this corrupt political
establishment
and you elected an outsider as president
who finally put
america first he says that in every
state he won
fire the corrupt politicians i don't
sound like a typical
washington politician it's because i'm
not one
politician probably wouldn't be here
and if i don't always play by the rules
of washington and the washington
establishment
it's because i was elected to fight for
you and i fight harder
and harder and harder
harder and better than anyone's ever
fought for you
we we were brought here we were put here
to fight for you
i had a very easy life before this i
have to tell you
he didn't have to be here with you
people thank you
consider the absurdity of the crowd
chanting thank you to the billionaire
thanking him for taking a break from his
great life to be their president think
about the stupidity
that we have in this country where
that's a chant at a political rally it's
sick actually this lady
she was actually one of the people she
said are you sure you want to do this
first lady people love the first lady
they do that
but she said uh but are you sure you
want to do this
i say i think i do yeah i think i do she
said you know you will win if you do it
you must be sure
you must be sure she said sir
let's run for president the question do
you want to do it i said yeah we do
we have to set this nation back on the
right course
right talk about narcissism oh she said
that i'll never forget that was sort of
cool
you know you're just like second nature
you know you win
running against a lot of very talented
people
and then we had a run against a very
talented crooked machine
joe biden is bought and paid for by big
tech
big media and powerful special interests
you saw that over the last couple of
weeks
all the corruption and they refused to
even talk about it could you imagine if
i got three and a half million from the
mayor of moscow's way
or one of my kids took three and a half
million from can you imagine that
and they refuse to even discuss it they
don't want to discuss it
there is no proof they now say the
laptop from hell
was produced by russia this was shift
watermelon head
right the laptop
was produced by russia and we say oh
no not again this is the pre you guys
know this is the president right john
ratcliffe came
out immediately he's great he's doing a
great job he said it was not produced by
russia
but that's what they try and do they do
disinformation did you hear
did you hear someone yelled biden's a
pedophile that's now a thing
they control biden and they know he will
always do whatever they want
they know that that's why they want him
i definitely don't do what they want
i definitely don't
it is weird trump making fun of other
people's physical appearance i know
their ratings will collapse every one of
them will be out of business they'll be
out of business so fast
every corrupt for an answer it won't be
it will be
they will be out of business so fast in
fact i think they're going to get
together the new york times will die
the failing new york times washington
post which is basically a lobbyist for
bezos you know that
they'll all get together and they'll say
listen we made a big mistake here
we got to draft trump we got to get him
to run again this is no good right
nobody cares can you imagine that having
biden we're going to put something up
can you imagine having biden as your
president
the biggest loser will be the fake news
media they will any second trump's going
to go into the specifics of that health
care bill from three months ago we're
going to hear how that's going to work
you know why everyone's watching
politics because they find politics to
be much rougher
than the nfl it's much dirtier and more
disgusting
and and they don't change you know the
nfl they change the rules they make
everything like coming back you can't
touch anybody
somebody tackles too hard they say
15-yard penalty and you're out of the
game and you're out for the season you
know the old days right
it was a little different but it's still
tough but this is much tougher
and people see it but you have to see
the ratings that's that's why the
ratings are bad for a lot of the sports
right nobody ever thought of this but i
thought of it a couple of people wrote
it
the ratings are bad because so many
people are watching this it's
tougher yeah trump's rallies are
effective
please please run again we think we're
going to endorse i got
endorsed by the pittsburgh
right pittsburgh post-gazette
he's not sure he's asking other people
72 yes sir yes
that's a big deal a big juice very good
very liberal newspaper but that's okay
but first time since
1972 that they endorsed a republican so
it's an honor and
if you don't read the first two or three
paragraphs it was one of the best
endorsements
if you if you don't read we don't like
paragraphs
yes he has a horrible personality but
listen to this
it's not that i do but i have been under
siege
illegally right three and a half years
i've been fighting for three and a half
years he's going to name the laws that
were broken here guys get ready
if the fake rusher hoax and all this
crap with the impeachment over nothing
over a phone call that was perfect
perfect
i wonder what it would be like if we
didn't have all of this horrible stuff
and and so it is the exact same speech
from last night so i i'm going to open
up the phone lines myself if you want to
talk to me
we will continue monitoring this but i
want to hear from some of you guys you
can go to davidpakman.com
discord that's d-i-s-c-o-r-d uh get in
the waiting lobby if you want to talk to
me waiting lobby
and make sure that you have discord set
to do not disturb or we will be hearing
really annoying
noises and we will have to hang up
unfortunately
and um change your nickname to location
colon name so if your name for example
was jebediah and you were in
wasilla you would put wasilla colon
jebediah okay that'll give us perfect
audio and it's davidpakman.com
discord i'll get myself connected and
remember
if once you connect listen to the stream
through discord because otherwise you'll
be on a delay and it'll be really
embarrassing when i try to talk to you
i'm here tonight great people in the
white house but it's true i wonder why i
wonder
if it would have been different you know
if they didn't because these world
we caught them spying on our campaign
we caught them trying to take out a duly
elected president in
the united states that's treason that's
treason
we caught them and someday
maybe something's going to be done about
it too you know
maybe
oh boy oh boy oh boy i can't we don't
want to do anything prior to the
election well what about me
they did it they did it to me before
they spied on my campaign before the
election here we go
we shouldn't do anything prior to the
election
and you know who we caught barack
hussein obama
and joe biden they were a part of it
we ought to get these reports out they
should get them out before the election
right i'm concerned you should get them
out right before the election
should have gotten them out a long time
ago we have we have information you
wouldn't even believe it i don't even
get involved i always said i'm going to
stay uninvolved
very hard all right let's let's i want
to hear from some of you guys let's go
to davidpakman.com
discord remember if you want to talk to
me get in the waiting lobby the audio
waiting lobby
make sure you understand how discord
works change your nickname to location
colon name location colon
name uh let me first go
to um let me go to tucker from vermont
tucker from vermont you are on with me
what's going on
hello david can you hear me yes i can uh
all right my uh question to you also big
time fan
i uh started watching you uh back in
december 2019 when the election started
rolling around
so thank you for that uh my question to
you is
um back in the last debate trump had you
uh brought up this
uh this factoid about vermont which is
very true
in that our state governor tried to get
past
a single-payer system yes um and that
had ultimately failed so uh my question
for you is
is it truly impossible for states to
implement their own single-payer system
since they don't really have the big
weight of collective bargaining that a
whole
country would have i think it is
possible my i don't know the full
uh monday morning quarterbacking on what
happened in vermont but my understanding
is that there was some pretty
significant mismanagement and also it
there's a double there's a double side
there's a double-edged sword in vermont
which is because it's a
state that has a small population um
it's easier
to do something like this and to test it
but on the other hand
because vermont geographically i mean
it's small but it's not tiny and the
population is very spread out
that it presents a challenge for doing
it so my understanding is that it's it's
not
there's nothing systemic that was proven
that wouldn't work
because vermont failed i think it's more
complicated than that and there are
specific reasons why
oh i truly agree my biggest thing is um
a lot of feedback
on the reasons that you just said where
our markets are very small we're very
rural
and our people are generally healthy so
they don't rightly have
a large need of healthcare so um it's
one of those things where i don't
i don't know if you know the states
could go around the federal government
and pass that if they didn't have big
enough markets
to begin with i think that it can be
done in states of various sizes
but it's got to be done right and
hopefully listen if if democrats take
the senate and joe biden wins i would
love to see another state give it a shot
yep that's all the questions i have
thank you for taking my time all right
thank you very much uh there is vermont
let's go next to rim from the country of
latvia rim from latvia you're on the air
hi you hear me yes i can
awesome i'm a like a longtime fan i'm
curious uh
why you were skeptical about florida
going to uh
trump i i heard you were uh
saying that it will would go to him but
uh yeah so i i have some people that
work in democratic politics in some
particular parts of florida
and they all are saying the exact same
thing which is
um when you look at early voting it's
almost perfectly split
be 50 50 not 50 50 but it's perfectly
split like
40 40 or 35 35 between democrats and
republicans
and then the independent vote is about
20
or whatever the numbers are what i'm
hearing is the independence
including a lot of latinos are
ending up with more of them are ending
up with trump than we might imagine and
that that's the reason that there's some
concern about florida going biden but i
mean the good news is
trump needs florida biden doesn't need
florida yeah
all right okay by the way are you are
you a native english speaker or
or because your english is excellent if
you're not oh thank you i i get that
a lot but uh i guess i've just uh i've
lived a lot abroad
i guess got it all right well listen i
hope i hope you're with us for the
election tomorrow night definitely i'll
i'll be watching
very nice uh okay excellent
let's go next to um
let's go to adam from montreal adam from
montreal you were on next
adam from montreal you were on you can
unmute yourself i would love to hear
from you
last opportunity for adam from montreal
all right and adam from montreal is gone
gone let's go next to
a tie from kansas city now is this
kansas city missouri
or kansas city kansas hi david can you
hear me
yes i can uh this is on the kids side
oh my god i've never i've never known
anyone from the kansas side
uh i don't actually live in kansas city
kansas i live in the overall metro area
i'm actually in johnson county
okay wow so then you you're way out
there essentially
good all right what's on your mind all
right i have a non-political question if
i could
okay i've noticed when you uh get
callers
oftentimes you'll get irritated with the
background noise right
yes i wanted to ask do you think you
might have misophonia by any chance or
do you know what misophonia is
what is that is that an annoyance with
idiocy
um close i guess misophonia is a
sensitivity to certain sounds it's also
called
uh selective sound uh
i can't remember the uh you know i think
it's being triggered by your mic right
now if i have it
oh sorry about that no listen i
i i you you're on to something which is
like
if there's a can if there's leaf if i'm
trying to sleep
and there's leaf blowers going on
outside
it's over i'm up you know i can't that
there's certain sounds i can't sleep
through no matter what and they
definitely bother me but i don't know
that i have misophonia
okay well i say because i do when i hear
certain sounds it triggers um
like the sympathetic nervous system the
fight-or-flight response
snaps yeah what's an example sound that
would trigger that
uh loud cars for me oh okay okay yeah
i find the really loud motorcycles
annoying but more because i find the
people annoying it's not the noise
itself it's the idea that someone thinks
it's cool
to drive by outdoor seating and rev up
their motorcycle
well yeah i absolutely agree with that
yeah but it's also just loud
bangs people uh yelling just
stuff that annoys people just regularly
just makes me
very irritated unreasonably i can't
really control it does the soup you know
how some people slurp soup very loudly
does that bother you
yeah that's for some people misophonia
is chewing sounds people uh tapping on
tables and stuff
yeah for me it's none of those things
it's mostly uh
loud bass noises music someone said
farts in the chat farts don't upset me
no okay just
usually just yelling and loud bass
noises cars perfect
all right well we will uh i will get an
audiologist on here right away and we
will figure out if i have it
sounds good all right thanks very much
for the call a lot of things on people's
minds today
let's go to i don't know if it's
andrea or andrea from portland oregon
you're on
andrea andrea from portland oregon
you're on andrea andrea how are you
i'm great how are you i'm doing well
oh my gosh i am a huge fan thank you
um actually you know watching your show
has actually encouraged my teenage son
to learn
about politics and has actually
helped educate my mother who never
really learned anything
and just kind of voted not in her best
interest that's fantastic news
yeah no we've gotten my whole family
fired up and even my husband who never
voted at all
registered for the first time this year
and voted with me and it was really
exciting
that's that's incredible that's
fantastic you know it's really funny
andrew i'll mention this
we had a we had a phone call last week
where someone called in and said hey you
you know you convinced
you convinced me to vote that it was
brought to my attention got posted
in a bunch of like ultra left
reddit subreddits where people were
saying
stupid neoliberal pacman got people to
vote
for biden and it's like well yeah that's
the better option what you think i'm
going to participate in getting people
not to vote you is that what you think
i'm going to be doing it was really
weird andrea and more likely this phone
call
will be misused in the same way no and
my husband he
you know he used to think that well
trump was you know
you know america thought that we needed
a businessman and right
he goes i think we were wrong on that
right
now what was the route that made us
think that we needed something other
than a politician and that's still an
issue
well you know the question that i asked
back when mitt romney remember willard
mittens romney who was running for
president a few years ago
when he was running under the auspices
of being a businessman
the question i had at the time was what
evidence do we have that a businessman
would make a good president and i think
people would point to
some very obscure president who was not
a president in the modern like it was
completely irrelevant you know
and trump isn't even as good a
businessman as mitt romney like i don't
like
the business that mitt romney made his
money in um
but i find it predatory but at least
mitt romney was
a businessman whether trump just you
know made buildings with the money his
dad gave him i like self-made man
he was a inhere like i handed a
silver platter man like there was no i
started from nothing and worked
i love that biden i even i heard
something today where he's like why is
it that i am not qualified because i
didn't go to an ivy league school
right i mean does that make me less of a
man oh that moved me because
i mean i had my education from a state
school but i'm still a successful woman
right i can still teach children how to
like educate themselves prepare for the
future and do things
for their best interests and no question
we've gotten my whole family like fired
up and for my husband
to be a registered voter now and to be
excited with me
he's just like telling me honey just
don't watch a lot of the news like
i don't want your blood pressure to get
too high right
he's because he's a driver so he
definitely like once he realized just
how much all this stuff affects
even what he does just day to day he's
very excited
to see the outcome so that's absolutely
fantastic
uh it's a success story listen andrew
before i let you go
a taco is it a form of a sandwich or not
my husband's favorite food and so that's
pretty awesome you asked me about that
it's no it taco i think is a form of a
um actually you know what it's the form
of a sandwich because
it is two pieces pulled together
something in the middle right okay
looking at it yeah i know you're right
it is a sandwich because he loves eating
them because that way he can get him
and eat them while he's driving so there
is
some logic to that all right andrea
unfortunately that is the wrong answer
so i'm gonna let you go
okay
all right well you take care david and
thank you so much you've been so
wonderful i'm a huge fan
thank you very much appreciate that and
uh there is andrea from portland
absolutely fantastic let's go next to
lawrence from st louis lawrence from st
louis you're on the air
hi can you hear me yes i can awesome
can i weigh in on this whole taco
sandwich situation real quick
only if it's completely necessary
all right uh in that case never mind
okay if you have
an exact uh number prediction on the
election
you have an exact prediction you're
saying sorry whoa hold on a second
we're stuck let me let me let's back up
you have a prediction for the election
go ahead and give it to me
oh i think uh biden's up 6.5 popular
vote
85 electoral votes okay now when you say
plus 85
electoral that i i don't have the num
what exactly does that make the split
how many does uh
biden get uh
300 no like 312 313
okay so that's a bit of a more
conservative estimate than like 538 for
example
yeah i think he loses florida personally
okay yeah i think
georgia and ohio with both right and
then i'm i'm back and forth on arizona
as well
yeah so you it sounds like you're in a
similar spot i mean i'm being more
conservative than uh
than 538 for sure okay yeah all right
well we'll see who's right
somebody's going to be okay good luck
out there thanks for the call
all right thank no thank you you called
me i appreciate you calling i should be
thanking you
uh let's see here let's go next to
manuel
from tejas manuel you're on the air
manuel from texas
you were on
hello hello yes i can hear you now
oh my god okay i was not ready for that
um
uh but how do you call it oh so what do
you think
oh two things what do you think about
how to call it
uh biden's uh like kind of like
infrastructure plan
i think it's a good start however like
public transit especially with buses i
know he's a miller of a train guy and
everything
like public buses and stuff like that
i'm kind of like uh
i doubt he's going to really care about
that too much especially how
you know at least compared to a more you
know
grandeur or kind of grand uh great a
green new deal
right kind of require with more green
transportation on that
how do you kind of uh see about that
first it's a start i mean listen we're
trying to go from the guy who
who trump ran on he would do all this
infrastructure spending he didn't do a
damn thing
um and so we're trying to go the idea is
first let's get to someone who will do
something and then we can figure out is
it enough and can we do more but yeah i
mean like
like with you i would like to see a more
robust infrastructure plan
but we're trying to start riding the
ship so i will take anything that is a
plan
first and foremost that is true
and uh i'm not sure if you heard too
much about this and
uh like i'm not too much of an
infrastructure guy i know my friend
is so uh have you heard about kind of
like china
giving buses to like mexico and some
other
somewhat more developed but
developing-ish nations
no i didn't hear about that spread their
influence are these are these um
electric buses or what's the deal
uh so they're all electric like chinese
main buses kind of shows
hey you know we can oh
sorry about this is someone are you
taking another call now or
oh no no it's um siri oh my god
siri's getting triggered by our
conversation
um but how do you call it
well i love the electric buses let's
start let's let's we could leave it on a
high note there
yeah for sure for sure beautiful but but
it's kind of like china kind of showing
its dominance
like with green energy in a way compared
to the us
yeah they're flexing essentially
basically yeah
interesting well no i did not know about
that but i will research
all right uh it's great to hear you uh
from uh david
thank you so much and we will see you
tomorrow for the election night stream
by the way let me
just remind everybody we are going i am
going to just take a brief
break from uh the calls just to paste
the link for tomorrow's youtube stream
in the chat
even if you plan to watch on twitch or
not at all
please go in there like it and set
reminder
it really helps us uh in the youtube
algorithm to have a good stream
okay we're taking calls via discord
let's go next to grace
from michigan grace from michigan you're
on
hey how are you good how you doing good
i am doing text banking tonight okay
so yeah it's um it's been it's been
interesting um i'm actually surprised
uh how many people respond back to text
messages versus phone banking because
i've done both
phone banking and text banking and i
will tell you people
often they will answer your text
messages before they'll take your phone
call
do you get a lot of like trump people
who are like screw you get me off this
list
they'll do things it's not always like
screw you get me off this list so
they'll say
go trump they'll say go gomagga trump
2020. those are pretty common responses
i've gotten like oh i voted for it i
didn't vote for hillary
um so it's all over the place
um but and let me ask you some i get
some of these
are you using like a computer interface
where you're seeing the responses on a
screen like you're not actually using a
phone
no no i am using my uh computer
interface
got it so yeah yeah we've actually
thought about doing some tech stuff on
the show where we could start building
up a texting list
and you know like gary vaynerchuk does
it and there's some other
nobody's really doing it in my
independent media space and i always am
trying to think of new things like
when we went on twitch there weren't
that many left political streamers on
twitch i know hassan was on of course
and
and that's he's huge but there wasn't a
lot of it going we're trying to be early
to certain things
we were early to igtv and now a lot of
our clips on igtv get 40 50 000
videos and supposedly igtv will monetize
next year
i'm thinking about starting to do some
kind of text thing
yeah they use what's called through text
is what we've been using
so and it's work it works out really
well because you're not giving out your
personal number
um of course they i do get a lot of
responses of
people you you're they're getting the
same text messages from people it's
annoying
yeah and and we get it like like we get
it
so um but it is like really important to
you know
do these polls and you know it's nice
when people respond because then we can
mark it down and
get kind of an estimate of who's voting
and what they're voting for
all right good well let's uh let's hope
for the best tomorrow
yeah well it's kind of i would say some
like right now even just doing what i've
been doing tonight and i've been doing
this for like six
hours from like the afternoon
until this evening um i will say it is a
toss-up
you think it is you're saying what
what's the whole thing is a toss-up
yeah okay there i have gotten i have
gotten
like yeah i'm doing it democratic
obviously but
it is it is a toss-up wow
well yeah let's hope it goes in our
direction
i'm hoping so have a good evening all
right thank you so much
there is grace from michigan
shot out of a cannon today let's go
next to uh daryl from new york
daryl from new york what's going on
daryl from new york you are on
hello yeah what's going on yeah what's
going on
hi how are you doing good how are you
i'm pretty good
thanks um yeah i wasn't expecting for
you to pick up
but um i guess my my my question
is um what do you
you know what do you think of people
still saying
like uh there's still gonna be riots
and like violence i really don't think
there's gonna be a lot of
violence because um i'm a flight
attendant i fly around
to different cities domestically and i
don't know everybody seems on their
best behavior everyone seems civil like
i see people of
trump hats and you know i'm black also
so they greet me
and um i don't know when i go out into
the country things don't seem as bad
you know in the country um but what's
your thoughts on that do you
believe like it's the end of the world
no listen it's not the end of the world
i think that if
tru if by the the safest scenario from
the standpoint of violence
is biden wins in a landslide i think
if biden wins by a little bit and trump
says it was rigged
i think that's the most dangerous
scenario i think if trump
claims victory and it's tight and it's
not really clear if he won
i think that there will be some clashes
and then i think if trump wins
overwhelmingly
you will see huge non-violent protests
from the left
combined with so-called peacekeeper
militia types from the right and it also
has the potential to get pretty crazy
and i guess my only other question is
it's like it's so obvious
that there's so much voter suppression
like
i don't think donald trump's even trying
to hide
the fact that he's trying to suppress
votes and trying to make these new rules
on the day of
election right i mean at some level
like is this kind of illegal
like like well the problem with that is
whether something is illegal this stuff
is going to go to courts and
courts will decide essentially if it is
or isn't it that that's the complexity
where colloquially
we all say like of course this is
against the spirit of
in front of of people being able to vote
an enfranchisement
but in the technical sense courts may
decide and that's scary
yeah well thanks david this is the
highlight of renee i
i listen every day and you know keep
doing what you do let me ask you this
i'm curious is there any are you aware
of
any strain of david pakman viewership
either among other flight attendants or
even pilots
i do notice i talk about it all the time
i actually stream i'm not supposed to
but i stream
your videos while i'm flying and i love
it
so uh but uh i tell everybody about you
what equipment are you on these days um
mainly the boeing 737
and the airbus airbus what like 320.
uh 3 19 320 321
america uh my job
yeah yeah we'll try to cut that out yeah
no i mean it was
yeah yeah your airline thank you
yes my airline they have uh the airbus
321t
which is mainly for trans cons that's my
favorite one because that's uh it's like
a three
class uh aircraft that you know it's a
first
business and main cabin and right like
the most exclusive i love it
yeah i had a few very very powerful
opportunities uh to ride up front on
that on
there were i think early it was being
used on boston lax and it was maybe even
a swap in when that first was released
and it was it was wild
yeah we also do boston to new york on
those yeah
all the time so right it's awesome
that's a flight i try to avoid if i can
yeah
yeah okay all right thank you very much
let's hope for the best tomorrow and uh
to the pilots and flight attendants you
know we really appreciate uh the fact
that
you guys are still doing it at a time
when it is difficult to do it
it's our pleasure thanks dave all right
very good
uh some perfect phone calls today i must
say
let's go next this will be interesting
let's go to victoria from
caracas is this caracas
well i'll speak in english just to save
you the translation process
but i've been watching you for about two
years three years and
well i've been in the states uh doing
grad school
in texas specifically and it's been such
a breath of fresh air to hear someone
who is you know stands by you know
humanist
liberalism but is balanced and you know
anti-authoritarianism in general so
thank you i'm really grateful for your
your work and your coverage and i really
respect you so you're from
caracas but you're you're in the u.s
currently yeah i'm currently in the u.s
i'm in
in austin texas got it okay
um but yeah so oh well one on the taco
absolutely not a sandwich but discuss
that with
someone from mexico sure and
and then another thing that i wanted to
weigh in on before i go to my question
is
um someone speaking about china gifting
this to mexico yes um and it's that
china
has been actually on at the forefront of
clean energy and
any kind of clean energy and it ties
into like their
somewhat like economic colonization of
the developing world
right we're no longer the leaders it's
like the developing world is not coming
to us for advice on climate
and they're increasingly they're
increasingly not even coming to us
for products related to going green
oh absolutely not i mean with i wrote a
paper on
solar panels and uh well solar energy
and china has been
kicking ass with solar panel production
for
a decade nearly right they're really at
the vanguard of this
um and funny enough fastest growing
state for that is taxes
in the u.s and is that right obviously
yep
now is that that is that's not
population adjusted i'm guessing
no no it's well it's investment like
related and all just raw dollars yeah
yeah exactly um but yeah anyway going to
my question
is it's you know obviously this stems
from
you know reagan's incredible reaganomics
propaganda um
and how this impacted you know along
with the cold war
um americans perception of how the state
should or should not intervene in the in
an economy right
yeah it's just so fascinating
to hear that even like to this point
like i thought
that most people still trust
republicans with economic affairs yeah
it's crazy more than democrats
now that did start it's almost 50 50 now
interestingly in this election which is
like as close as it's ever been
i know and i mean what i think
what i want what i wanted to ask you is
i mean i study this
so how can we communicate to people that
republicans
not only does their botched
philosophy not work yeah they're also
terrible at it and they don't adhere
they don't govern economically well at
all they don't govern well but i don't
know the answer i've been thinking about
this for a long time
clearly just showing people facts and
charts doesn't work
um the sort of moralizing doesn't seem
to have worked
i don't know what the answer is but i
think that in 48 or 90 to 96 hours
we probably will have more of an
opportunity to think about what the
messaging
it has to be on that i i hope so i
really do hope that you know things turn
out well
and uh well thank you so much and
another thing is
argentina the best alfajores in my
opinion are igachofas
yeah those are good those are good those
here here's maybe let me ask you a
different question because you you came
down very powerfully on tacos
do you believe that an empanada is
merely a small
latin american calzone oh my god
this is a very puzzling question i don't
know maybe in argentina because
well i've been to argentina many times
but because you all have so many italian
immigrants maybe there it originates
i still say no i don't i think it is a
completely different thing
i no i i agree with you also because in
venezuela and the caribbean they're made
with
corn flour rather than like you know
wheat flour so
yeah i agree it's not a calzone no okay
yeah in argentina they're not made with
corn flour but even that notwithstanding
i
i say it is not a small calzone no i
i agree with you um but yeah all right
well
thank you so much i'm so glad you picked
up my call and uh
well good luck and i'll keep telling
everyone about your show
all right thank you so much there is
victoria from caracas
venezuela originally and now
uh in texas let's go to one more from
texas let me go to claire from texas
claire from texas what's going on with
you
hey hey david how are you good how are
you doing
i'm doing all right i wanted to actually
ask you a question
just out of curiosity are you listening
to music while we talk
oh oops i think i had something that's
some play in the background sounds like
heavy metal or something
oh no no no no heavy metal uh
i want to ask if god forbid
trump wins a second term yes what do you
think would be the next steps
on um reversing just basically like
trans military ban like continuing that
trend
uh i think it would only happen if
democrats take the senate and then maybe
the house and senate i mean i think
maybe trump would even veto something
but maybe not i don't know
i don't know but i think it's important
because a lot of what trump has done is
via executive order i think it would be
great to have a president
undo it by executive order yeah i agree
i agree yeah i'm just really concerned
because i know in like indiana i believe
they're
pushing for like okay you know
they're i think they're trying to ban
trans athletes
in certain sports it just it just really
concerns me as a trans person
and yeah well the the you know the
athletic stuff i think is different
the the right loves to talk about
athletics like the forefront issue on
trans rights
is whether someone born uh biologically
male
should be able to be a female wrestler
if they are a trans woman
the the right wins when they make that
the issue i
actually don't think that that is really
where the focus should be
and i can't help but think that the
right wins by talking about stuff like
that
i think you're partially right just
because i yeah i agree i don't think
it's the biggest issue
when it comes to trans rights i think
like the trans military ban
they also proposed housing rules to
discriminate against trans people it
just really scares me
yep i understand why i understand why uh
all right thank you so much for the call
we'll hope for the best yep take care
claire from texas claire from texas all
right let's go somewhere else now
let's go to uh there's just so many
people who want to get
on here why don't we go to kenny from
berkeley
kenny from berkeley you're on hey
david can you hear me yes i can hey
what's going on how you doing
good are you ready for the impending
doom
what are you referring to so well i
don't i actually this leads me to my
question
um have you been checking the real clear
politics polls i just like them because
they take an aggregate
no strings attached it's just numbers in
numbers out
yes sorry about this um my question to
you
is if you've noticed all the poles are
all of a sudden kind of ticking upward
in the trunk direction
and yes they're staying relatively
stable with biden but
why is this happening again is there
something that the polls just magically
can't catch until like it's
november 1st or something well um
you're saying in j i don't know that
that's really the case
uh are you look at arizona um
in certain swing states okay no sure
yeah i mean like listen
wisconsin is very powerfully staying for
biden
in michigan trump's ticking up a little
bit but but so i think
you know um there's been nationally
there's been a little bit of a
tightening but part of that is because
real clear politics is including
uh polls that not everybody necessarily
includes i mean
i think what we have to do is compare to
previous years
is really the most important thing okay
that's fair um now i legitimately think
that
pencil as you said wisconsin is going to
stay blue i think pennsylvania is going
to stay blue
i think even if uh biden loses florida
it's going to be a very long night
tomorrow if so
but i i don't see how
trump has the electoral numbers here
unless he starts to really start to
throw wrenches into the system
it it counts on him getting everything
that
is leaning republican and flipping some
things he has to flip some things
because if you just go as i did earlier
safe republican safe democrat leaning
republican-leaning democrat
trump needs all safe republican leaning
republican
and he's got to take something else
that's leaning towards biden it's not
impossible though
right especially if he tries to put as
much strain on the system as he's
clearly showing signs of
wanting to do indeed indeed can i can i
ask you a kind of zoom out
question sure so
let's say things go according to the
numbers in 2020
and we get abide in presidency and the
country
well half of us or three-quarters of us
or two-thirds of assay a collective
you know big sigh of relief yeah do you
think that this sets up the stage for
the
republican party as we know it just from
sheer demographics to fall off the map
or do you think where do you think
the right goes in america from here i
think it would be too early to say
i think that of course we would all if
that were to happen
start to think that way but the party
has a way
of making adjustments at the state
levels in order to remain in contention
so i think it would just be too early i
think tomorrow's results won't tell us
what we need to know to answer that
question
that's fair all right then i'll call you
back soon okay thanks very much
appreciate that
um let's see where else do we want to go
today uh a lot of different people here
let's go to monique from the bay
area monique how are you
i'm doing great
great sorry this is my first time
calling
you're doing great so far what's on your
mind um
so over here in california i know that
we're going to be democratic
but um a lot of areas around here in the
bay area are kind of nervous about the
riots that are going to be happening
tomorrow
okay so um
when you say riots there are they are
they expected to be
who's going to be doing the rioting uh
we're thinking possibly the republicans
okay
and is that in any scenario or in one in
which certain
electoral outcomes happen um
i think in any scenario because of what
happened in san francisco
and what's happening like all around the
bay and
all that other stuff but my question to
you
is do you think uh americans have
worse stressors right now than other
nations currently
it's so tough to answer that because as
such a rich country
you can just as a starting point infer
that there are economic stressors that
apply
to a much higher percentage of the
population of other countries than in
the united states
but based on some recent polling you
know and everybody's dealing with the
with the virus
based on the failure here on coronavirus
and how it's worse than in just about
every other place
and the anxiety many are experiencing
according to a number of polls i've
looked at
i think it's plausible to say that right
now despite
on average being economically very well
off in the global
stage uh anxiety is running very high in
the states yes i think that that is a
fair thing to say with a variety of
caveats and clarifications
right because of that and you know
what's happening with like all the
weather
and the fires out here and the floods
and
all that stuff no doubt about it yeah i
mean and and you know the problem
whenever you do these things
is you know then somebody will say well
what about the abject poverty of liberia
or something like that and so it's not
so much about
necessarily comparing to other countries
but comparing
the change in the status quo from what
it was here in times past is
maybe more relevant right
okay well thank you for taking my call
thank you for calling in i really
appreciate that
okay guys we're going to call it donald
trump is still ranting and raving in
front of a
widely maskless crowd these are all the
same this is the last day
of campaign rallies tomorrow 7
p.m eastern okay please please
please join me i am pasting once again
the link to tomorrow's uh stream
in the youtube chat i am pasting it in
the twitch chat even if you plan to
watch
elsewhere or not at all please hit the
like
and the set reminder button on youtube
it will very powerfully trigger support
of our stream in the youtube algorithm
i will see everybody tomorrow with the
final podcast youtube clips tv and radio
show before the
election the final bonus show for
members and patrons before the election
and then election results tomorrow night
i will see you then
you